[Música]
gracias por estar con nosotros en una
nueva emisión de reporteros comenzamos
sudán es un país lleno de riquezas
arqueológicas pirámides y tumbas además
de templos que se extienden a lo largo
del valle del nilo pertenecientes a la
antigua ciudad nubia de meroe una de las
ciudades capital de la dinastía nubia
que gobernó el reino de cus entre el
siglo quinto antes de cristo y el
tercero después de cristo hoy en día
muchos de estos sitios antiguos y
herencia invaluable como las famosas
pirámides de los faraones negros carecen
de protección y ahora esos tesoros están
amenazados por las nuevas urbanizaciones
por los ladrones de tumbas y por los
cazadores de oro situación a la que el
país le busca una solución nos acompaña
el odiosa autora del reportaje que
ustedes verán en unos minutos y empiezo
por preguntarle qué tan difícil es
cuidar todas estas riquezas
arqueológicas
porque hay miles de estos sitios en
sudán y una gran mayoría de ellos aún no
ha sido descubierto ya sea porque
todavía están enterrados bajo tierra o
porque desgraciadamente ya han sido
destruidos
pudo haber sido por un agricultor que
necesitaba más tierra para cultivar o
por niños que querían jugar al fútbol en
medio de una ruina o simplemente por
alguien que buscaba algún artefacto
en los últimos años se han hecho grandes
esfuerzos en algunos sitios por ejemplo
en bomboya o el asa como verán en el
informe hay que entender que en sudán la
gente puede realmente pasearse
libremente por el interior de las ruinas
entrar en las pirámides o inscribir sus
nombres en los restos y nadie se lo
impide de transcripción sobre llegó
abrir aunque persona también
invitados entonces a ver el siguiente
reportaje
[Música]
mucho menos célebres que sus vecinas
egipcias las pirámides de meroe albergan
las tumbas de cuarenta soberanos del
reino de kurt
las más antiguas fueron construidas en
el año 720 antes de cristo-
me sudan los sitios arqueológicos se
extienden a lo largo del valle del mío
desde principios del siglo 20 hay
arqueólogos que tratan de comprender
esta civilización de la que tan sólo el
20 por ciento de los vestigios han sido
descubiertos
[Música]
nos encontramos en el sitio arqueológico
de bomboya y se trata de un sitio
satélite del imperio medio ético una
estructura política más antigua de toda
áfrica sub-sahariana que sirve
probablemente de centro cultural y
administrativo de acumulación y
redistribución para el estado central
seis arqueólogos están a cargo de unos
quince obreros que provienen de los
pueblos de los alrededores cuatro
semanas de excavaciones por necesarias
para hacer surgir los cimientos de esta
edificación construida en el siglo
primero de nuestra era de lo que se ve
por ahora creo que se trata de una casa
y allá hay un templo se nota por la
orientación de la entrada
si se acerca verá que la puerta está en
esa dirección
bajo esta colina se oculta una gran
edificación durante su próxima misión
dentro de un año
los arqueólogos sondearán la tierra
esperan descubrir un templo que les
permitirá comprender mejor la
importancia del sitio la labor debería
durar una decena de años y hay que
considerar una excavación arqueológica
tal como una investigación policíaca
donde en cada capa que se quita la idea
es comprender la situación en la que nos
encontramos para meternos en el
pensamiento de la persona que haya
construido la estructura o haya hecho
una cerámica o una tumba para enterrar
un cuerpo
para que esta investigación llegue a
buen término hay que proteger los
vestigios expuestos a numerosos peligros
alrededor de don boya los agricultores
son los que representan el mayor peligro
a veces deciden instalarse en un sitio
arqueológico con frecuencia
inconscientemente los arqueólogos le
encargaron a este hombre la supervisión
del sitio esta mañana conversa con el
representante de la comisión de las
antigüedades
hay peligro de amenaza sobre este sitio
hay personas que te generan problemas o
algo así gracias a dios no aquí la gente
ha entendido que hay que aceptar a los
arqueólogos esto ya ha sido benéfico
para nosotros y lo será aún más en un
futuro el trabajo de estos dos hombres
es primordial antes los vehículos de los
campesinos circulaban encima de los
cimientos de las edificaciones es más
sencillo si es un sudanés el que habla
con los habitantes del pueblo y les
explica desde un extranjero diciendo se
trata de un sitio arqueológico y vamos a
trabajar aquí es la parte más importante
de nuestro trabajo y también es lo más
importante para lograr proteger este
sitio don boya es perseguido como una
zona de trabajo modelo en la región
además del aporte financiero que
representan las expediciones desde hace
20 años los habitantes son formados de
generación en generación la mejor manera
de proteger un sitio arqueológico como
este no son sólo las barreras o las
protecciones o el registro catastral es
ante todas las comunidades locales que
son conscientes de la razón por la cual
se realiza este
de trabajo y del hecho de que se
reapropien de su patrimonio
[Música]
el jefe de los obreros que supervisa la
obra cuando los arqueólogos no están en
el lugar
solo debe recorrer unas decenas de
metros para regresar al pueblo
como al final de cada jornada acoge a
sus hombres para el té los arqueólogos
no los han generado problemas tomaron
una parte de las tierras pero los
habitantes aceptaron la situación y no
se enojaron esperamos que cuando todo el
sitio haya sido excavado haya turistas
que vengan a nuestro pueblo para ello
será necesario que la situación política
se estabilice dos años después de un
golpe de estado
al día siguiente los arqueólogos
preparan su recorrido hacia jartúm
[Música]
abandonamos la obra y avanzamos a lo
largo del nilo hacia el norte
[Música]
en la ciudad de abril varios hombres se
unen a nosotros espontáneamente en
nuestro hotel
tienen antigüedades para vender
este tendría un objeto interesante es un
fragmento de mesa de ofrenda de la época
mero ética generalmente dispuesta frente
a las tumbas
[Música]
en general paseo y visitó los pueblos y
cuando veo un lugar que ha sido
registrado y lo recorro y giro para
encontrar cosas
aquí está ya estaba rota cuando la
encontré
otro habitante nos propone alfarería
todos imaginan que ello puede costar
mucho dinero
en cuanto lo quieres vender alguien
compró una por 1300 euros
en realidad estos objetos no tienen
ningún valor solo los arqueólogos pueden
sustraer de ellos información valiosa
logramos convencer al vendedor de
alfarería que nos conduzca a ver la
tumba que está saqueando esta roca
estaba arriba la quité con un buldózer
la puerta de la tumba debería estar por
aquí un rumor recorrió la región estos
hombres creen que encontrarán estatuas
de oro y harán fortuna fácilmente
l
en su interior hay dos piezas si
logramos ingresar ganaremos millones más
de lo que podemos contar
cuando reventamos todo esto tendremos
más dinero del que podamos soñar esto
podría enriquecer hasta 50 personas en
realidad está por destruir una tumba y
probablemente no obtendrá nada la
creación de numerosas minas de oro en la
región generó una estampida hacia las
antigüedades son dejando la tierra para
encontrar el metal precioso los mineros
descubren vestigios con frecuencia en
medio del nilo la isla de saint está
rebosada de siglos algunos de los cuales
son de la época del paleolítico
los habitantes obtuvieron recientemente
la autorización para buscar por
[Música]
aquí hay una beta la primera que hemos
encontrado de leer
esta es la veta principal y encontramos
mucho oro pero en cuanto más excavamos
más disminuye el porcentaje pero bueno
algo se encuentra para excavar tan
profundo trajeron una excavadora
la mina está ubicada a unos cientos de
metros de una necrópolis edificada en el
tercer milenio antes de cristo
la tentación era muy fuerte con la
esperanza de encontrar objetos de oro
los obreros destruyeron todo a su paso
los policías ubicados cerca niegan los
incidentes
y las destrucciones en la necrópolis de
karma tuvieron lugar hace mucho aquí no
hay nada nuevo
desde que estamos aquí y este sitio es
el más cercano nada ha ocurrido
siempre estamos cerca
falta de personal para impedir el saqueo
complicidad nadie sabe por qué los
policías no reaccionaron
imposible proteger los miles de sitios
arqueológicos sudaneses
entonces el gobierno decidió apostarle a
la educación
la misión francesa regreso a jartúm
mcmillon desempaca los tesoros traídos
de don bosco
esta es una decoración con motivos
florales y la pintura es de origen es
decir que tiene más de 2000 años
también encontramos objetos un poco más
simpáticos como por ejemplo estos
fragmentos de estatuas que representan
una pata de león acostados y ninguna
estatua de oro desafortunadamente no no
la buscamos especialmente para ser
francos es más un problema que otra cosa
si la encontramos
porque por un lado hay que protegerla y
por otro lado queremos evitar los
problemas que pueda crear la presencia
de oro en un sitio arqueológico es decir
los saqueos
tiene cita con el director de la
comisión de las antigüedades de sudán
gracias a un subsidio de la alianza
internacional para la protección del
patrimonio en zonas de conflicto
pudieron desarrollar un proyecto
pedagógico para explicarles a los niños
y que no hay que destruir los vestigios
de uno la idea es imprimir 20.000
ejemplares de esta caricatura traducida
en árabe y en inglés para distribuirlos
en las escuelas de todo el país aquí
usamos la restitución de una ciudad mero
ética les mostramos el taller de
cerámicas la capa de cosas vayan bien
creo que un trabajo como éste cambiará
muchas cosas en la mentalidad de los
niños
a ti mal no nos lleva a la reserva del
museo nacional donde están conservadas
las piezas más importantes encontradas
en las expediciones arqueológicas
hay de todas las épocas una de ellas
atrae especialmente nuestra atención
se dice es un pedazo de arenisca de
forma cuadrada una tableta de ofrendas
it's not for in que se parece
enormemente a la que el cazador de
tesoros trato de vendernos le mostramos
las imágenes
se trata de un fragmento verdadero me
avergüenzo cuando veo que nuestro pueblo
destruye su patrimonio y su cultura
ello significa que hemos perdido
informaciones de nuestra historia
desafortunadamente aquí la ley es muy
débil no te tronco o no sirve de nada
castigarlos con tres meses de prisión se
sin de prisión cuando una multa de cinco
euros de find
no es nada tu salsa su denny's pawn its
nothing detrás de las puertas de la
reserva
la sala principal del museo nacional
como puede ver todas estas vitrinas
están vacías porque evacuamos las
antigüedades de sudán national museum el
museo nacional está siendo renovado
renovation los visitantes regresarán
dentro de dos años
el objetivo es acoger a los alumnos de
todo el país
soy optimista porque todos los ladrones
son personas sencillas que sufren por
asuntos económicos e incluso de
económicas y tuviesen
acuden a esta vía para encontrar oro
pero los detendremos y uno lo que
informó gol no mediante la fuerza en tu
stop the air force back baile sino
explicándoles la importancia de todos
estos sujetos con sólo dice lo dice
variable materia
[Música]
y otros museos regionales deberían abrir
a lo largo y ancho del país
los arqueólogos sudaneses quieren actuar
rápido pero la situación económica y
política los frena ahora esperan
estabilidad para poder llevar a cabo los
numerosos proyectos que les permitirán
salvar su patrimonio
regresamos con el lúdicos autora del
reportaje que ustedes acaban de ver hay
muchos saqueadores de tumbas a pesar de
que no ganan mucho económicamente porque
y muchos de ellos son jóvenes que
trabajan en las minas de oro y buscan
ganar dinero extra con sus herramientas
de minería quieren acabar por la noche
requiere mucho trabajo y los hallazgos
son pequeños pero los rumores son muy
fuertes y no tienen nada que perder
jueves
y nunca
por eso cuando alguien dice cosas como
he oído esto y lo otro o conozco a
alguien que ha conseguido vender una
pieza de cerámica por diez mil euros
realmente quieren creerlo pero como
vimos en el reportaje el saqueador de
tumbas que seguimos nos explicó que se
tarda 15 días en destapar una tumba con
una retroexcavadora y al final no
encontraron nada o en todo caso nada de
valor nada
hay ladrones de tumbas que destruyó en
estos sitios pero no son los únicos
responsables de los daños esto usted en
las pirámides de meroe puede decirnos
qué ocurrió allí
si los primeros buscadores de tesoros
fueron europeos el más famoso fue el
italiano giuseppe ferllini desertor del
ejército quien destruyó unas 40
pirámides enero en la década de 1830
cuando éstas acababan de ser
descubiertas
no buscó piezas de joyería de oro y
plata que hoy se exponen en museos de
múnich y berlín su única ambición como
la de muchos saqueadores actuales era
hacerse muy rico fueran cuales fueran
las consecuencias externo gesplán porque
consejos
bueno pues muchísimas gracias a lüthi
por este reportaje que nos trae hoy en
france 24 ustedes gracias por
acompañarnos y recuerde que puede seguir
esta emisión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web las 24 punto com hasta la
próxima semana
[Música]